or 60 kilometers far from cebernet7 the
massacre took place uh immediately
uh on that day it was the 14th of july
when they started uh
killing and uh somewhere around midnight
uh
my turn came and i was uh
i i was found myself in the hole
that i was forced to take off my shoes
my clothes to the waist and i was
tied my my hands were tied in in
my back and uh later in 10 minutes
i was on the place for mass executions
it was a difficult moment for me
uh i i realized that the it was the end
but
uh uh what i what i thought at that
moment
yes that i that is that i uh just
thinking that
i would uh uh die
fast without suffering uh and uh
at that moment i just uh started to at
the thought
the think my mother and
uh that she would never know where i uh
ended up and uh probably probably uh
when i was uh in front of the
execution squad i was shocked because i
uh
at that moment i noticed the rows and
rows of dead bodies in front of me
and uh i don't remember when i was hit
but later i remember that i
was uh lying i was shivering and uh
trembling and the bullets uh were
hitting everywhere around me and i
waiting for next
month uh come and kill me at that moment
i was uh i was hit in the
in my stomach in my right arm and uh
the pain was unbearable for me
and uh i just waited for next bullet to
come and
end my suffering uh
many voices were crying everywhere
around
around me they were moaning and uh
in one moment the soldiers started uh
killed them again and uh i remember that
uh the military booth
just stepped just up in
in front of my eyes at the moment i
thought uh
and he came to kill me but he
he killed uh he killed the the guy
beside me
and uh at that moment i
i could see uh how some people
uh uh enjoy in in uh
in our suffering and such things are
unimaginable for me but uh
that were difficult moments and i just
waited to die i
i i wanted to die at that moment but i
didn't dare
to kill me and later they
they left the places and uh i was
uh left to die there they
they didn't notice that i was alive but
soon after that i
no no one could imagine that that
that that i could survive even even
of soldiers could imagine that that
someone could survive
because so many bullets hit uh
every everywhere and uh and i
uh often i would say that there was a
their mistake because they didn't check
all the bodies
and uh after that
i noticed the other survivor and we
helped each other and escaped
the place of massacre before the next
before the the before another truck
arrived again